よーし……もう3月も終わりかけだ
気合い入れていくぞ！
ドン ウッ ンッ……ティッ
はいっこんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
というわけで、もーー
3月も終わりかけで！
春休みも終わる方多いと思いますが！
あの、僕もですね実は
YouTuber的に3月って、なんか忙しい月でぇ
最近マジでちょっと いましd…忙しすぎるんですけどもー！
なんとか、3月も頑張ってこれたなって思います！
はじめしゃちょーです
おつかれ。
はいっというわけでですねぇ
ま、シャーペン……
まぁ前回のシャーペンの動画
ちょっと記憶喪失を起こしてしまったんですけどもー
今回は全くたぶん大丈夫だと思います
いままでになかったシャーペン
ご紹介しようと思います
ぜひ新生活が始まる方とか
学校始まる方とか
文房具なんか変えて気分一新したいなんて方は
ぜひ！見ててください。
こちらッッ！！
まぁまずはー
ま、これは紹介したことあるんですよ
デルガードですねー
うん、たぶんね、紹介は紹介は(？)全然したことある…と思うんですけどもー
まぁ、これも結構レアなカラーリングらしいんですよ
黄色のデルガードです
まぁデルガードのいいところ
こちらも力を込めて書いてもシャー芯が、折れません
この芯先のここが、シャー芯折れるのをガードしててぇ
力んじゃってシャー芯折れやすいよって方はぁ
すごいおすすめのシャーペン デルガードってあります
ってかもうきょの…黄色ってのがかっこいいですね！
これはたしか限定カラーなんですよ
映画がですね、バングラ・ビートってやつを観まして
トランスフォーマーの別の話みたいな
もうなんか黄色いものなんかすべてめっちゃかっこよく見えるんで
これマジですごい今……
[ﾁｭｯ]
っていうですね、デルガードってやつがあるんですけども
結構いろんな色のラインナップがあるんですけどもー
今回みなさんにご紹介するのは
マジでかっこいいです。
結局ねぇ、シャーペンってのはねぇ
あの
どんなに良いシャーペン使っててもー
勉強のやる気が出なかったら意味がないんですよ
そういうことなんです
つまり！
ま、性能も大事ですけどもー
さらに僕、大事だなと思ってるのは
カラーリングとかデザイン！
だって、いい車乗っててもダサいと嫌でしょ？
いい車乗ってても、色が例えば
変だったら
嫌でしょ！？
ということなんです
みなさんが好きな色とか、やる気が出る色があると思うんですけども
それもシャーペン一緒で
好きな色、好きなデザインのシャーペンを使ってたら勉強のやる気が
自ずと出てくるんです。
それがいわゆる
ってやつなんですよ
黄色好きな人は、これ使うとめっちゃやる気出ると思うし
僕もですね赤いシャーペンとか
黒赤とか白とか使うとめっちゃやる気出るんですよ
というわけで今回みなさんにご紹介するのは
デルガードのなんかめちゃくちゃ
レアなカラーリングってかデザインがあるので
そちらをですね、全部買いました
いきますよ
まずはこちらです、はい
ジュジュン！(？)
デルガードのMARVELコラボでございまぁす！
こっちがアイアンマンコラボですね
ちょっとあとでしっかり見ていきましょう
で、これが？
キャプテン・アメェリカ
のデザイン
で、こっちがシンプルにMARVELのやつ。
1個だけ届くのが遅かったんですよ、レアなのかなぁ
これだけめっちゃ来るのに時間かかりました
はい
アイアンマンの別カラーでございまーす
2種類あります
や、デルガードは全然使ったことあるんですけども
このデザインのやつ見たときぃ
[息を吸う音]
えぇぇえええ！！
かっこいい！！
真っ剣にマジでかっこいいって思いました
だってもう、MARVELとのコラボよ。やばいよ！
どうしたらこんなかっこいいデザイン作れるんだろうってぐらいカッコイイ…
なんか値段がですねぇ
1728円で、ちょっと高いです
MARVELヒーローのように
強く！折れない！
そんなデルガードをモチーフにした
MARVELコラボのデルガードが販売されたみたいでございます
あ、でもやっぱ最近だな…
たぶん2019年…今年の2月3月ぐらいにはもう出てますねこれ
あれっ、てか、もう1個あるんだこれ
これワイ将軍、買えなかったやつがあるんでたぶん、もう1個ですねー
スパイダーマンのがあるんですよ
てことは5色展開かな
なんか色んな種類があるんですけど
とりあえず僕が買えたのは、えっと
アイアンマンが2種類と、MARVELのやつと、キャプテンアメリカのやつの4つでございます
ちょっと開けていきましょう
デルガードですね、何がいいかというとこれ、重心がすごい低いんですよー
ちょっと力込めるだけで、スラスラスラ〜って書けるっていう利点があります
MARVELのマークがしっかり入ってて！
まぁ真っ黒っすねこれは。
ベースが真っ黒になってます
では次キャプテン・アメリカ開けていきます
いやこれほんとにね
どのヒーローが好きかっていう好みですねー
僕はもうアイアンマンがやっぱ赤なんで、好きなんですけどもー
んおぉぉお……
メタリックブルーっすねぇ
ちゃんとここにキャプテン・アメリカの マークが付いてます
いーや、オシャレだなぁ……
やっぱ青っていいっすよねぇ
そして、アイアンマンの金赤ですね(強調)
てかYABA！
ここのクリップが金色なんですよ
なんだこのただならぬ、ッ高級感は
ロゴもしっかり入ってるしぃ
ペン先、赤ってのもかっこいいすよねー
これかっこいいけど
僕はもう1本のこっちの方がたぶん好きなんですよ…(惜しげ)
はい
アイアンマンの、レッドゴールドカラーです(強調)
え？これもうなんなら一番かっこよくね？え、やばいよ
ここは一緒なのね、ここ一緒ですね
ちょっとMARVELコラボ全部かっこいいすねこれぇ…
さらに、ここに、スパイダーマンの赤青のやつもありますから
黄色を足すとこんな感じですね
やばいもうカラーバリエーションがすごい増えてます、デルガード
もちろん書きやすさもすごいっすよー⭐︎
折れないっていう安心さがあるんで、すごい思いっきり書けますねぇ
しっかりと書けるイメージがすごいです
てかやっぱ、金って目立つよね
金がやっぱり人の目を引く色だと思うんでー
それに僕の好きな赤が足ッ…されてるっていうともう…
もう…
1番かっこいい↑↑(けんすけ風)
はい、というわけでいかがでしょうか
もぉ〜〜〜……
全部
いいですねぇ〜♡
マジでセンスを感じます！！
キャプテン・アメリカの偉大ぃなぁ青な感じ
そしてアイアンマンの熱い心、そして鉄板 のような金！！
金赤とか赤金とか今までなかったのでー
とてもいいところを突いてくださったと思います
ゼブラさん、ありがとうございます
というわけで、MARVELコラボのシャーペン、マジで全部かっこいいです！
ぜひみなさんも手に入れてみてくだ、さいっ！
じゃあなっ！
まぁMARVEL観たことないんだけどな？